l'annoncé tombée comme un coup de massue
sans activité depuis six mois les
salariés de mulhouse heures avait
demandé la mise en liquidation de
l'entreprise
mais le tribunal ne l'a pas entendu
ainsi à la grande surprise du personnel
on n'a pas compris on comprends toujours
pas cette nouvelle ce verdict et qu'elle
logiquement 9 n'aurait pas dû tomber on
s'attendait à une liquidation totale la
société en effet l'entreprise affiche 2
3 millions d'euros de déficit les
ateliers ont été vidés et selon les
salariés
il n'est plus possible de construire un
tunnelier au creusot reste maintenant ce
sursis de six mois pour trouver une
porte de sortie favorable à tous en
espère maintenant que le redressement et
va servir à quelque chose que ça ne sera
pas encore une perte de temps ce qu'on a
déjà perdu beaucoup de temps depuis le
rachat en novembre 2018 par la société
milder donc là maintenant il faut
vraiment qu'on trouve une solution
rapide soit il on arrête cette société
et puis bon on cherche du travail
ailleurs ou un vrai repreneur avec une
vraie envie de nous faire travailler et
un avenir pour pour nous quoi contactée
par téléphone la direction estime elle
que la situation est très difficile avec
des commandes potentielles qui se font
attendre et elle affirme travailler à la
recherche d'éventuels repreneurs